Vsauce Kevin here we're in an era where
crime scene investigators lab techs and
detectives seem almost superhuman some
of the best shows on TV blend forensics
and data to analyze criminal Behavior to
a remarkable degree you would think
everyone is Sherlock Holmes and it is
true that our use of Science and Math to
solve crimes and to understand the
people who commit them is advancing
rapidly but Jennifer Thompson's
eyewitness identification of her
attacker was flat out wrong and a broken
police lineup methodology encouraged an
error that put Ronald cotton in prison
for a decade both a judge and jury
misunderstanding simple probability
convicted Janet Collins for an assault
and robbery she had nothing to do with
the truth is as we advance we run into
serious problems new limitations and
unintended consequences I've spent a
year studying stories that reveal the
delicate balance of scientific progress
and Justice these seven videos have been
compiled into one long-form viewing
session for your convenience and I'll be
back at the end to discuss what we've
learned first up imagine the FBI
arresting you for an act of terrorism
that happened over 5 000 miles away and
insisting that International authorities
have somehow forensically tied you to a
bomb on another continent you went to
bed Innocent but because a faulty
fingerprint analysis you woke up a
terrorist
Vsauce Kevin here imagined the horror of
being arrested in connection to a crime
the entire world is reading about on the
basis of irrefutable fingerprint
evidence that you know you didn't commit
how do you defend yourself against a
century of Science and Math that just
aren't wrong and how can you possibly
win when you're up against the FBI and
your own fingerprint expert says your
fingerprints are a match the first
arrest of an American connection with
the Madrid train bombings what led the
FBI to Portland Oregon supporters of the
men say agents are on the wrong track
foreign
[Music]
they call it 11 m
on March 11 2004 just three days before
Spain's general elections explosions
ripped through trains in Madrid
193 people were killed and about 2 000
were injured Europe hadn't experienced
an attack on that scale in decades and
it came in the wake of 9 11 and at the
peak of the global war on terror
fingerprints were found on a bag that
contained detonating devices and Spanish
authorities put them into the Interpol
database the FBI in the United States
found a match to latent fingerprint 17
and in May Brandon Mayfield a U.S army
veteran and family law attorney who
frequently worked with low-income
clients in Portland Oregon took the
blame how does a lawyer
5403 miles away from a crime become its
prime suspect to understand what went
wrong here we need to go all the way
back to Darwin throughout the 1800s
scientists Advanced the notion that a
pattern of epidermal ridges on human
fingertips toes and Palms were unique to
each human and they could be used as a
proof of one's identity like a built-in
biological signature Scottish surgeon
Henry folds proposed that they could be
cataloged and recorded with ink and he
asked Charles Darwin for help Darwin was
a bit too old to undertake a real
analysis so he passed it on to his
cousin Francis Galton whose many
accomplishments included identifying the
statistical regression to the mean and
inventing a physical board to
demonstrate it that we now see on game
shows the science around fingerprint
identification flourished and by the
beginning of the 20th century it had
become one of the best ways to pinpoint
criminals and especially repeat
offenders it replaced systems like
branding skin which France outlawed In
1832 it was much more scientific than
Alphonse bartian's anthropometric
forensics a measurement of physical
factors including head length head
breadth lengths of middle finger length
of the left foot eye color and hair
color by assigning values for each
bechtyon claimed each person would have
a unique combination of data except it
wasn't all that unique since so many
physical attributes correlate with one
another like most tall people also have
long arms you don't find many five foot
three men with seven foot wingspans
fingerprints were much more accurate and
berthian developed a system of 16
identifiable markers that remained
standard for over a century starting in
1924 the U.S government began compiling
and cataloging fingerprints and by 2004
they had about two 100 million on file a
wavelet scalar quantization algorithm
was employed to compress the 500 pixel
per inch images down to a file size of
just 500 kilobytes which meant easier
storage quicker access and smoother
online transfers globally like to Spain
and by that time it had been a century
since Francis galton's forgotten warning
that a complex pattern like fingerprints
is capable of suggesting various
readings as the figuring on a wallpaper
may suggest a variety of forms and faces
to those who have such fancies remember
that even though the prints sent from
Spain were low quality an FBI examiner
signed an affidavit stating that the FBI
lab stands by their conclusion of a 100
positive identification
yeah in the weeks leading up to his
arrest Brandon felt like he was being
watched because he was literally being
watched FBI documents show that as soon
as Brandon's fingerprints popped as a
potential match he was immediately under
24-hour FBI surveillance including phone
and digital monitoring he also suspected
break-ins at his home and in his office
because they were both really broken
into they were convinced Mayfield was
involved here's a question if
fingerprints are so foolproof why was an
innocent man harassed by the government
entertained for weeks as he wondered why
they thought he was connected to a crime
on another continent Spanish authorities
actually knew Mayfield's print wasn't a
match before the FBI detained him they
communicated a result of negativo after
their own fingerprint expert found too
few points matching in the prince so
would the FBI do the FBI flew to Madrid
and told them they were wrong as they
investigated Mayfield they found that
he'd converted to Islam they also noted
that a year prior to 11m he'd
represented a man accused of involvement
in a terror plot in Oregon the more they
looked into his life the more
circumstantial evidence they found that
suggested Mayfield had the means and
motive to play a role in the attack and
that's actually the punch line to a joke
about a lying Texas Sharpshooter the
jokes about a man who shoots at the side
of a barn and then draws a Target around
a cluster of bullet holes to suggest
he's actually a great shooter when
that's done with data it's called the
multiple comparisons problem when we
falsely perceive Connections in our
heads it's epiphenia and when you're
fitting evidence to a predetermined
conclusion that has a name too
psychologist Peter wayson coined the
term confirmation bias to describe one's
tendency to focus on evidence that
supports their beliefs and to ignore or
reject evidence that contradicts it
basically it's cherry-picking the truth
and it almost guarantees you'll find
exactly what you're looking for even if
that isn't reality so what was the
reality
foreign
years after the incident admitted that
Mayfield was actually one of 20
potential matches to the lf-17
fingerprint once they looked into
Mayfield's life and found details that
supported their suspicions he became the
prime suspect because he served in the
military he probably had the knowledge
to be involved his tangential past
connections to suspected terrorists were
further proof and since he'd converted
to Islam he checked almost every box on
the FBI's profile list and when they
searched Mayfield's house evidence was
seized from his residence including what
the FBI called
Spanish documents they turned out to be
his son's Spanish homework okay okay
okay but why did Mayfield's own defense
experts agree with the FBI that his
prints were a match they both claimed
there was an unusual similarity between
the two prints with the office of the
Inspector General noting that they
considered the coincidence to be quote
extraordinarily rare and now we're back
to people being accused of crimes based
on hypothetical low probability just
like Sally Clark's tragic case in my
last video the FBI deliberately
manipulated their conclusions By
ignoring that the lf-17 print was only a
slight match with Mayfields and then
they focused on evidence that supported
Mayfield's guilt and ignored the parts
that didn't but the FBI's bad judgment
was also a function of a weird problem
we have when we get better at collecting
and using data think of crime in
galton's Era there was essentially no
real information to work from it was
very difficult to verify a suspect's
identity it was hard to find a suspect
given that there was no video evidence
hardly any photography and primitive
forensics at best it would be
Generations before we could begin to
collect and process things like blood
types and DNA the FBI didn't have too
little data they actually had too much
they knew every little detail about
Brandon Mayfield's life from his browser
history to what was in his garbage the
sheer volume of information made it easy
for them to find exactly what they were
looking for and only what they were
looking for here's an example of how
that data and knowledge Gap quickly goes
wrong Swedish power lines in 1992
Swedish researchers concluded a 25-year
longitudinal study to determine whether
living near high voltage power lines
made people sick they studied the rates
of over 800 different illnesses and
found that childhood leukemia was four
times more common near power lines their
data wasn't wrong the problem was by
measuring so many variables they
basically guaranteed that at least one
of them would be a weird statistical
outlier and then they used it as proof
of a cause and effect relationship you
you could actually visualize what this
is like look if I have a huge bag of
dice and dump them all on my table
what's gonna happen most of them will
form a scattered pile right under where
I dumped them but you know that one or
two of them are gonna fly off my table
bounce on the carpet and Lodge
themselves under a filing cabinet 10
feet away
why they're outliers it just happens
all right back to Mayfield the FBI had a
preconceived notion of who was likely to
have been involved in 11m they had
seemingly reliable forensic evidence to
support a suspect's identification they
had so much information about that
suspect also easily available digitally
that they could find information that
perfectly fit their profile they
dismissed the high volume of exculpatory
data like whether Brandon Mayfield was
even in Europe before 11m he wasn't his
passport had expired years ago but the
FBI claimed that meant Mayfield must
have traveled under another identity
for them the absence of proof was proof
Mayfield was detained for two weeks as a
material witness not arrested as an
actual suspect since holding him as a
material witness required far less
evidence the FBI kept collecting
information they thought proved
Mayfield's guilt but everything came
crashing down when Spanish authorities
announced that they found the person who
was actually involved in 11m they
matched the lf-17 print to those of an
Algerian terrorists and they were right
the FBI experts agreed that these prints
were truly a match
Mayfield was released immediately and
then the questions began as the American
civil liberties Union and other civil
rights Advocates excoriated the FBI for
having wrongly profiled him the FBI
analyzed what went wrong internally they
laid part of the blame on what they saw
as the poor quality of the original
digital image of lf-17 but a panel of
international fingerprint experts
suggested that the FBI had far too much
confidence in the integrated automated
fingerprint identification system which
is the largest biometric database in the
world and let the pressure of a high
profile case determine how they viewed
the evidence and what evidence they
collected at all the panel also
concluded that FBI culture discouraged
fingerprint examiners from disagreeing
with their superiors the Department of
Justice released a 330 page report that
admitted to analytical and procedural
errors and academic journals churned out
articles analyzing the validity of
fingerprint analysis the rate of false
positives and fingerprinting's role in
criminal trials regarding the validity
of fingerprinting a science historian at
UC Irvine said how do you explain to the
court that what you've been saying for
100 years was exaggerated but you still
have something meaningful to say
bayfield's case led to lawsuits about
potential misuse and constitutionality
of the Patriot Act a two million dollar
judgment in his favor and a formal
apology from the U.S government Mayfield
went back to practicing law nearly two
decades after Mayfield's unconscionable
Injustice we have even more data and
information about everything and about
everyone it's amazing how much we can
know and how quickly we can know it
everything from medical records to
finding a gem mint Charizard is way
faster than it used to be and usually
more accurate that's generally a good
thing
but sometimes all that information is a
problem even when it's perfectly
accurate the way we use it might not be
we can make good data bad and it's
getting even more difficult to get it
right Mayfield's case highlights the
complex relationship between the
objectivity of Science and Math and the
fallibility of the human mind as we
advance we find more ways to be right
and that also means more ways to be
wrong
they're not quite 100 reliability of
fingerprint analysis may have initially
failed Brandon Mayfield but the
unchecked flaws of the human mind are
what landed him in a jail cell
sometimes the math and science are right
and the way we use them the way people
use what's right is wrong and as always
thanks for watching
Vsauce Kevin here with a serial killer
who may very well have murdered hundreds
her systematic Killing Spree went
undetected for years because suspicion
just wasn't enough what finally brought
her to Justice was Matt don't leave me
here they're gonna kill me they kill
people here you know I did it I did it
you wanted to know I killed those guys
in the United States the most dangerous
place you can go is the hospital yes
doctors and nurses save lives literally
every single day but medical error is a
significant cause of death no matter how
hard we try tragedies happen and by
definition everyone in a hospital is
already sick with something but murder
isn't an accident and a nurse in
Massachusetts was straight up killing
patients to impress a guy
Kristen Gilbert was a nurse at the
Veterans Administration Medical Center
in Northampton Massachusetts she was
popular with co-workers she'd go out
clubbing with them in Boston to blow off
steam and even through baby showers she
also seemed to be really good at her job
it felt like she was always around to
save the day in an emergency
she appeared to be the perfect nurse but
Gilbert was around so often when
patients died that other nurses jokingly
referred to her as the angel of death
it seemed like the Northampton hospital
had a lot of unexpected deaths but a VA
investigation found that the hospital's
rate of deaths was in line with similar
VA hospitals so case closed right wrong
doctors and nurses weren't convinced but
there were no Witnesses who saw Gilbert
actually do anything suspicious to
patients there wasn't any evidence but
there was Data here's a question how
often did patients die when Gilbert was
on the floor compared to when she wasn't
was there a correlation between her
presence and patient deaths and if so
was it just an unlucky coincidence or
was she killing people
the first analysis can be expressed
visually this graph shows patient deaths
in the hospital Ward between 1988 and
1997 broken down into three shifts Day
evening and overnight the 4 pm to
midnight evening shift stands out as
having the most deaths and Kristen
Gilbert worked the evening shift but
that doesn't hold for every year 1988
and 89 don't match up with the six years
that follow it there weren't that many
deaths and they were pretty evenly
distributed throughout the day Kristen
Gilbert didn't start working on the ward
until 1990. okay okay what about the
really high number of deaths during
overnight shifts in 1990 that's an
outlier in this whole data set Gilbert
worked evenings but when she started in
1990
she worked the overnight shift
huh
[Music]
yeah
graph is still not proof variation in
human outcomes is tremendous whether
it's education or physical fitness or
death it's totally possible that Kristen
Gilbert was present during a statistical
blip it's possible there's some nurse
out there working on a floor where
patients never seem to die like some
kind of angel of life just ask Brandon
Mayfield whether coincidence has
happened or the FBI Dr Stephen gellback
who is now Dean Emeritus of UMass
Amherst School of Public Health ran the
numbers he looked at
1641 nursing shifts over the period of
18 months leading up to staff taking
their concerns to hospital management
there were 74 deaths during those shifts
which is a death on 4.51 of all shifts
or .045 deaths per shift Kristen Gilbert
worked 257 shifts during that 18-month
period with .045 deaths per shift we'd
expect her to be present for about 11 or
12 deaths about one every six weeks on
average 15 or 16 deaths when you expect
11 or 12 could be an unlucky statistical
anomaly she was there for 40. 40. a
patient died on over 15 percent of
Gilbert's shifts what are the chances of
that literally 1 in 100 million and
maybe even less in the handwriting
analysis I did of Sylvia howland's will
Hedy Green's forgery matched on way too
many points to chalk it up to a crazy
coincidence one in sextillions gilbach
calculated p-values to estimate the
chance of Gilbert's nursing death rate
at less than 1 in 100 million but we
know from the Sally Clark trial that a
probability like one in 73 million isn't
necessarily what it feels like it is
correlation isn't causation maybe her
patients were just sicker than normal
this time that uncertainty was okay it
was enough for the grand jury to proceed
a grand jury doesn't have to determine
guilt or innocence the way a trial does
they just decide whether the evidence is
compelling enough to proceed with
criminal charges they did again there
wasn't proof but the math gave enough
context to the suspicions of the
Veterans Administration Hospital
management and Gilbert's co-workers to
proceed with charges but how was she
killing these people and why prosecutors
allege that Gilbert had injected
patients with epinephrine which you
probably know as adrenaline which sped
up their hearts and caused cardiac
failure adrenaline is untraceable but
the hospital found that it had a lot of
epinephrine go missing during Gilbert's
employment and some of the patients like
Henry huden who was relatively young and
a paranoid schizophrenia patient weren't
likely to have three heart attacks in
one night without something artificial
really causing it but why would a
professional mother of two in Suburbia
become a deranged super villain
well she seemed to have delusions of
grandeur in which she herself put
patience in critical condition and then
heroically tried to resuscitate them she
had a history of manipulative Behavior
mental illness and abuse of patience as
a home care aide in the 1980s she
scalded a mentally disabled child with
hot bath water on purpose Kristen
Gilbert may have been unhinged but she
was also in love
obsessively in love every time a patient
coded Hospital policy mandated that a
police officer engaged in CPR in late
1995 and early 96 these same police
officer responded to every single
Cardiac Arrest that Gilbert reported
James perrall Kristen's boyfriend the
man she left her husband and two
children for Witnesses noticed her
touching paroled affectionately during
resuscitation efforts and wiping his
sweaty brow court papers show that one
witness will testify that he observed
Gilbert playing footsie with peralt
during the middle of a code gross
Perrault ended the relationship and
Gilbert was angry on a phone call from a
psychiatric facility she confessed to
him by saying you know I did it I did it
you wanted to know I killed those guys
parole immediately went to the
authorities so she called in a bomb
threat to the VA hospital where they
worked Decades of troubling Behavior
culminated in a systemic Killing Spree
that allowed Gilbert to be the focal
point of Crisis after crisis staff
testified about her access to the
adrenaline that induced cardiac events
and doctors testified that the
unexpected excess deaths were often
relatively healthy middle-aged men the
same pattern just kept happening Kristen
Gilbert was convicted of four murders
and two attempted murders and the bomb
threat to a federal facility it's
possible and probable that she was
involved in many many more patient
deaths that weren't the accidents they
seemed to be but prosecutors couldn't
prove it she could have faced the death
penalty but a compassionate judge and
jury sentenced her to a life in prison
without the possibility of parole plus
20 years the mathematical analysis that
was so critical to Gilbert's downfall
wasn't even used in the trial the trial
judge ruled that the statistical
evidence was prejudicial as it likely
wouldn't be understood by the jury as
not being Ironclad numerical proof of
her guilt I've shown that math can be an
incredible asset in court or that it can
turn innocent people into criminals
we're getting used to Scientific and
mathematical evidence like DNA and
forensics determining guilt or innocence
but the reality is math and science
don't have to do all the work dozens and
maybe hundreds of veterans are alive in
Massachusetts because of a bar graph
math and science don't always have to
put out the fire
sometimes all they should do all they
need to do
is sound the alarm
and as always thanks for watching
they saw us Kevin here Jennifer Thompson
studied every detail of her attacker's
face as she was being sexually assaulted
at knife Point his hairline broad
cheekbones a mustache that looked like a
Pencil Thin dirt smear she couldn't
fight back physically but mentally she
could memorize every little detail and
bring him to Justice police described
Jennifer as the best witness they'd ever
had her eyewitness testimony convicted
Ronald cotton and he was sentenced to
life in prison plus 50 years despite no
physical evidence linking him to the
crime there was no evidence because he
didn't do it and 11 years later DNA
testing proved it so how could the best
witness ever get it completely wrong why
do about 70 percent of DNA exonerations
in the U.S involve eyewitness
misidentification
and how can what we've seen turn into
something we never saw
I need you to point to the shape that
rolled over your foot on the evening of
March 14 2015.
okay this example seems stupid but it
shows one of the many many problems with
witness identification only one shape in
the lineup comes close to the
description of the suspect the choice is
obvious only a circle can roll
now this lineup requires an actual
identification of size and color but
here's the question how do you even get
to a lineup first you need a description
Jennifer Thompson studied pages of ears
chins and noses so police Could
reconstruct her attacker's face using an
identicate in 1984 that was a sketch on
paper now the identicate is digital the
hand-drawn facial composite looked
nearly perfect to her now the police had
a picture of the suspect that could be
broadcast on the local news here's the
problem some witnesses are amazing their
autobiographical memory of an event is
Flawless but then there's the rest of us
and Hugo munsterberg wrote the book on
how what we forget and what we don't
know becomes an illusion that replaces
reality in 1908 munsterburg published on
the witness stand collection of Articles
and essays about psychological factors
that affect trial outcomes what's more
persuasive than a witness pointing to a
defendant and swearing they did it
Monster Berg insisted that gold standard
of evidence in a trial was actually
really untrustworthy trials predate the
ancient Greeks and while we've always
known Witnesses could lie only recently
do we understand how easy it is to think
you're telling the truth
when your brain is just wrong
munsterberg suggested that Justice often
miscarried due to the treachery of human
memory and to prove it he pointed the
finger at himself he wasn't some
academic pontificating on criminal
justice theory he was robbed and as a
witness he messed it all up it went like
this he testified under oath that
burglars entered his house through a
window they actually came in through the
cellar he said they left a clock packed
in paper it was wrapped in a tablecloth
he gave a complete list of garments that
were stolen it turns out they took seven
more than he said he claimed he found
candle wax on the second floor but the
wax drippings were actually in the Attic
finally he reported two burglars but
maybe it was just one he had no way to
tell monsterberg had given over 3 000
academic lectures and not once had to
use note cards his mind and memory were
amazing but he admitted that he'd rushed
into the house and surveyed it all
quickly noting after the fact that his
brain filled in the gaps for him the
burglar was eventually caught breaking
into another house and they found
monster Berg's jacket in his apartment
but the fact is the world's expert on
witness reliability was almost
completely wrong he said I felt myself
somewhat alarmed in seeing how many
Illusions had come in
so if the pioneer of witness reliability
scholarship couldn't overcome his
Illusions what chance did a college
student traumatized by a violent sexual
assault have
police presented Jennifer Thompson with
a photo lineup of six men they told her
that the suspect might not even be in
the lineup but she figured if he wasn't
there why would they bother she
recognized one of the photos and chose
Ronald cotton with absolute certainty a
week later Jennifer recognized the same
man in a physical lineup to her the
parts that didn't match her memory made
him even guiltier like he'd changed his
hair to purposely deceive her the photo
lineup reinforced her mental image of
her attacker and anti-proof became proof
police confirmed that she'd chosen the
same man in both lineups she said it was
him there was no doubt in my mind did
you feel absolutely certain absolutely
certain well what was said to me
afterwards was that's the same person
you picked out in the photo lineup
so in my mind I thought
bingo
I did it right how can the truth compete
with that estimator variables are the
parts of eyewitness identification that
police can't control so like cross
racial IDs tend to be less accurate than
IDs within a witness's race that isn't
the police's fault people think
different things and they just plain see
different things from an optical
illusion to the colors of a dress
but the real enemy of memory is time
Herman ebbinghaus's forgetting curve
provides a visual representation of how
quickly your memory can erode and as
early as the 1880s his equation
expressed the vulnerability of memory
over time but forgetting over time is
only half the problem the other half is
teaching yourself the LIE every time you
retell your story to police to a lawyer
to a journalist to a friend you're
essentially engaging in the space
repetition of practice you're learning
your memories get clearer almost like
memorizing lines for a play so the
longer it's been the more you forget the
more you forget the more you invent the
more you repeat the more confident you
are whether it's true or not
Jennifer Thompson said if there was a
death penalty I wanted Ronald cotton to
get it I would pull the switch if they
let me when she pointed her finger at
cotton to identify him during the trial
she said she wished it had been a gun
Ronald cotton had become her attacker in
Her Mind through unconscious
transference but there was no physical
evidence no fingerprints no clothing no
fibers from the victim's apartment
linking Ronald cotton to the crime he
maintained his innocence and refused to
entertain a plea bargain
was convicted based largely on
Jennifer's testimony
three years later Jennifer Thompson came
face to face with her actual attacker
and didn't even notice Ronald cotton was
given a new trial that's great right
wrong this time he also faced charges
for another assault and burglary from
that same night meanwhile he'd met a man
in prison who looked a lot like
Jennifer's original composite sketch and
he looked so similar to Ronald cotton
that other inmates couldn't tell them
apart Bobby Poole lived in the same town
as Ronald and Jennifer and he was
currently serving a sentence for sexual
assault if all that wasn't enough to
raise suspicions he'd literally confess
to other inmates that he assaulted her
Ronald's lawyers called Bobby Poole as a
witness in the new Triumph Poole denied
everything Jennifer Thompson had wanted
to be the one to personally execute
Ronald cotton but when she was in the
same courtroom as her real attacker the
man whose face she'd studied she didn't
recognize him at all Ronald was
convicted again and sent back to prison
Richard Rosen a professor at UNC Chapel
Hill and lawyer Tom Lambeth took on
Ronald's case they secured the DNA
analysis that wasn't available in 1984.
Ronald insisted that he'd be cleared and
the stakes were high a DNA match would
cement his guilt
Ronald wasn't lying the test showed that
Not only was Ronald Innocent but that
Bobby Poole was the attacker and over 10
years after first being arrested Ronald
cotton was free
Jennifer didn't dispute the DNA findings
she knew she'd been proven wrong she
wasn't defensive about it she was
horrified she said I had to tell people
Not only was I a rape victim but a rape
victim with an extremely bad memory and
someone had to pay 11 years for that
I wondered how I could have been so
stupid
Jennifer was not stupid during the
attack she actually convinced Poole to
get rid of his knife then outwitted him
by offering to get him a drink and using
the distraction to escape
she just fell prey to the
vulnerabilities all Witnesses have and a
few simple changes can drastically
improve witness reliability lineups that
offer a range of similar choices are
most effective that way suspects can't
stand out and making lineups sequential
so one photo at a time is compared to a
witness's memory instead of being
compared to one another is even more
effective police need to make it clear
to witnesses that the suspect might not
be there and the cops who make the
lineup shouldn't be the ones who
administer it that double-blind process
ensures police can't give any verbal or
non-verbal cues to the witness to
influence their choice recording the
lineup solidifies the record and police
should ask witnesses to detail their
level of confidence in their choice
but Jennifer Thompson would have said
100 percent
and advancing science was the only thing
that saved Ronald cotton from a life in
prison
in my mind I was sure what I saw
[Music]
um
thinking back on it uh I don't know that
I would have done anything different
Jennifer and Ronald are friends now he
never blamed her for being wrong they've
given talks together Nationwide their
families are close and they even end
phone conversations by saying love you
half the states in the U.S have
instituted some form of eyewitness
identification reform but can we make
sure what happened to both Ronald cotton
and Jennifer Thompson never happens
again
probably not Hugo munsterburg was right
from biological limitations to
systematic error the moment our eyes and
ears capture something the truth is
vulnerable
we can get better but will never be
perfect 2 200 years ago the Roman
playwright plotus said that one
eyewitness is worth 10 ear Witnesses
people attest to the truth by saying
they saw something with their own two
eyes they'll tell you that something is
so good you need to see it to believe it
but the truth is
sometimes you need to believe it
to see it
and as always thanks for watching
Vsauce Kevin here with the dumbest math
ever used to convict an innocent person
in a court of law it all started with a
little old lady in an Alleyway and it
ended by defining how we use
probabilistic evidence in trials with
the California Supreme Court warning
that bad math could become a veritable
sorcerer to ruin law almost 60 years ago
a petty neighborhood robbery you've
never heard of changed everything
foreign
[Music]
named Juanita Brooks was walking down an
Alleyway when someone shoved her to the
ground she looked up to see a blonde
woman running away and that woman had
taken Juanita's purse at the end of The
Alley a man named John bass witnessed a
white blonde woman with a ponytail get
into a yellow car and drive past him he
saw that the driver was a black man with
a beard and a mustache these sound like
the basic facts of the case but they
ended up becoming numbers and it
happened because of total uncertainty
John bass saw that the woman had a
ponytail Juanita Brooks couldn't
remember if she did a police officer
asked around local gas stations until he
found someone who said that an
interracial couple filled up their
yellow car there frequently Janet
Collins and her husband Malcolm they'd
only been married for two weeks and now
they were being arrested for robbery
when Juanita Brooks and John bass were
asked to identify Janet and Malcolm from
photos neither one could do it Juanita
completely blanked and bass only saw a
resemblance in the ponytail the police
still had some case their Alibi was a
little shaky Malcolm had a criminal
record and a recorded conversation with
police showed Janet's desire to take the
blame to protect her husband and that's
when desperation kicked in the
prosecution turned Juanita Brooks
assault and theft into a probability
problem prosecutor Ray cinetar brought
in a professor from Cal State Long Beach
to help him prove to the jury
mathematically that Janet and Malcolm
Collins were guilty the professor
testified to the validity of the product
rule which is that if events are
independent you can multiply the
probability of each to find the chance
that they happen together for example if
thing a has a one in five chance of
happening and thing B has a one in 10
chance of happening then both of them
happening separately but together is one
in fifty or two percent so what did
Scimitar do next he started literally
making up numbers cinetar invented six
vague estimates touching on the only
details that John bass and Juanita
Brooks could provide here's what he said
he said the chances of a black man
having a beard were one out of ten that
a man would have a mustache one out of
four that a white woman had blonde hair
one out of three that a woman had a
ponytail one out of ten that an
interracial couple would be in a car one
in one thousand and that a car would be
yellow one in ten
sure the professor was given a pencil
and paper to work out the probability of
those six events happening together
using the product rule and he did the
answer was one in 12 million and that
was it he left the witness stand
yeah if you watched my video about Sally
Clark you know exactly what's Happening
Here the prosecutor explained to the
jury that this sort of mathematical
proof was actually better than the
concept of proof Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt because it dealt with hard numbers
instead of vague beliefs he called it
the new math and he said it would help
convict the people who push old ladies
down and take their money he said that
Malcolm and Janet Collins were the only
two people in Los Angeles who could
satisfy all the elements of probability
in this case he suggested that they had
to be the one in 12 million because with
all those pieces matching up how could
they not be but this wasn't new math it
was bad math and it was still enough to
convict the Collins's of second-degree
robbery and in Jim Crow era Los Angeles
there was almost certainly an element of
racial bias supporting it Malcolm
Collins appealed his conviction and it
went to California's Supreme Court and
they finally obliterated the
prosecutor's stupidity the math was
obviously wrong starting with the
completely bad up odds of each
characteristic it's not like the
prosecutor analyzed the vehicle
registrations of all California
automobiles to determine that 10 of the
state's cars were yellow he didn't
conduct a massive survey of hairdressers
to find out what percentage of their
clients pulled their hair back into a
ponytail he just guessed then he failed
to acknowledge that these events are not
independent like beards and mustaches
you know they kinda tend to come as a
pair a lot not always but a lot so you
can't just straight up multiply them
like their coin flips but here's the big
one let's say the math is accurate which
it isn't you've found a couple who
satisfy all the conditions to be the one
in 12 million great how do they know
they are the couple who committed the
crime are they the only two people in
the Greater Los Angeles metropolitan
area who were a blonde ponytail and
black mustache and bearded couple in a
yellow car surely there weren't many but
there's a decent chance there's a few
the Supreme Court actually calculated
the probability that another couple
fitting the same exact description at
over 40 percent 40 percent so even if
the math checked out there's pretty
close to even odds that Janet and
Malcolm were the wrong couple
three years later Malcolm's conviction
was overturned and he was released Janet
had been given a short sentence and
she'd already served it the Collins's
never really got Justice Janet served
her time and Malcolm lost a few years of
his life but the Biggest Loser was the
validity of probabilistic evidence it's
the most glaring example of the
prosecutor's fallacy and it's taken
decades to undo the damage Rey sinatar
caused to the use of math in the
courtroom but the Fallout wasn't all bad
it did lead to the Collins test a set of
conditions the introduction of
probability needs to satisfy for the
math to be relevant and valid in a trial
one the probability factors need to be
accurate you can't just make them up two
the calculations are done correctly and
formulas are applied appropriately like
not abusing the product rule to get the
result you want three all the factors
being calculated actually apply to the
parties involved four and the evidence
proves there could be only one result so
that the Collins's could be the only
possible couple capable of satisfying
every condition the police never did
figure out who knocked Juanita Brooks
down and stole her purse in 1965 two
criminals in Los Angeles got forty
dollars richer and math got a lot less
trustworthy in the courtroom but without
it we don't have the Collins test or an
ever-evolving debate about how we can
leverage what we know about math to find
out what we don't know about everything
else
proving that sometimes things have to
get really done
before we can even start to get smart
and as always thanks for watching
Vsauce Kevin here Kevin Lieber actually
that's my name it's German but I'm not
the only one there are 10 other Kevin
leibers in the United States so what if
one of the other Kevin leibers is
connected to a murder of another
YouTuber three miles from right here and
the only surviving victim identified me
Kevin Lieber as the killer to top it all
off Mr Beast testified that I confessed
to this murder to him and I'm the only
one who knows I'm innocent all of this
actually happened not to me to a woman
named Joyce Ann Brown
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
they needed a conviction they needed the
pressure off two blacks in Dallas Texas
and Texas period walked in and bought
open daylight shot and killed a
businessman
somebody was going to pay
I'm that somebody on Thursday May 8 1980
the Dallas Morning News published a
short article buried in the paper's
local news section A shop called Fine
Furs by Ruben had been robbed and its
owner Reuben danziger was murdered his
wife Allah said Ruben pleaded don't hurt
me don't hurt me before one of two
female robbers shot him in the head
Allah escaped by telling them she had
terminal cancer with just weeks to live
one of the women said we'll just let you
suffer and left as police looked for
suspects they found the getaway car a
Datsun rented to a woman named Joyce Ann
Brown a police officer recognized the
name as someone who'd been arrested
years prior for a minor sex work charge
so they asked publicly for Joyce and
brown to come in for questioning Joyce
in immediately went into the police
station to clear up the confusion she
wasn't worried she knew she didn't do it
and she had an alibi she was at work
when the crime occurred and this is
where the incredible coincidences really
begin Joyce worked at coslow's another
first door just across town so she'd
presumably know which valuable Furs to
steal working nearby in the fur industry
with the same first middle and last name
as the getaway cars renter quite a
coincidence but even so Joyce denied any
involvement the interrogator told her
you're lying we know you pulled that
robbery so she was arrested and held on
one million dollar bail then police
realized that the Joyce Ann Brown who
rented the car actually lived in Denver
Colorado know she was a completely
different person in a completely
different state and that Joyce said that
she lent the car to a friend but by then
it was too late Joyce's mug shot from
her prior arrest had been shown in a
lineup to Mrs danziger who identified
her as one of the robbers and she said
that that woman had been in the store to
case it out in the weeks leading up to
the crime forget relying just on a weird
name thing now the police had an
eyewitness identification okay but what
about Joyce's solid work Alibi there was
about a seven minute window that would
have allowed Joyce to commit the robbery
leave the scene change her clothes drive
back to work and compose herself as if
nothing was out of the ordinary before
talking to a co-worker at 1 19 pm and
the police said that must be exactly
what happened but but what actually
happened none of the items recovered
from police searches the rental car
Joyce's apartment linked her to the
crime but when evidence starts to
suggest that weird things are
coincidences it's tempting to just come
up with new evidence suddenly a woman
named Martha Jean Bruce claimed that
Joyce had confessed to her while they
shared a jail cell after Joyce's arrest
Bruce said there was no incentive for
her to testify to that but remarkably a
few months later the D.A recommended
that Bruce B released over three years
early on a five-year attempted murder
sentence
so yeah the DA's investigator Ari
Christian found her story convincing
after I talked her a little bit in
detail she began to tell me some things
that indicated to me that she would have
had to have talked to someone involved
in that crime if because of the facts
that she had about the way the Furs was
supposedly uh baggage when when they
left the scene and Martha Gene Bruce had
that information she knew that they were
invested bags but she could have read
that in the newspapers oh and Martha
Jean Bruce had already been convicted of
lying to police but the prosecutors
ignored that the odds of it all being
the universe's cruel joke against Joyce
Ann Brown were just too much for the
jury she was found guilty and sentenced
and there was no hope that calculus was
ever going to be in her favor everything
added up for the prosecution and the
pattern checked out their case went like
this Joe Joyce and brown is the black
former prostitute in Texas accused of
involvement in the robbery and murder of
a holocaust Survivor on her lunch break
from work at the same type of store a
few miles away with the surviving victim
visually identifying her sworn testimony
of a jailhouse confession and the
getaway car rented in her exact name
here's a question what are the odds
someone with your name commits a crime
since there are only 10 other Kevin
liebers I'm pretty safe but what if your
name is Michael Stevens there are 2
975 total Michael Stevens's in the
United States how about John Smith he's
got 48
439 other potential criminal John Smiths
conversely Tanner butts in a sense is
firmly up to him six months after
Joyce's conviction The Other Woman
linked to the robbery and murder was
finally apprehended Renee Taylor Police
found Furs and the murder weapon in her
apartment she told police that she had
no idea who Joyce Ann Brown was but she
refused to give up the name of her act
actual accomplice because she didn't
want to ruin that woman's life Renee
Taylor was convicted of murder and sent
to the Mountain View Maximum Security
Prison where she served time with Joyce
and brown guards were ordered to keep
the two women apart Joyce is in prison
Renee Taylor is in prison but it took
years to determine who Renee's real
accomplice was a woman named Lorraine
Germany who'd also robbed in Albuquerque
New Mexico first store with Taylor and
an investigator told Joyce that Lorraine
looked enough like you to be your twin
sister name Furs doppelganger ridiculous
in 1984 Joyce's appeal was denied on her
birthday two weeks later her son shot
himself his last words to her were mama
when are they gonna let you out we don't
have a family anymore most crimes aren't
all that different from each other and
the details usually add up there are
often familiar patterns the Dallas
Police fell victim to The Angst along
effect a cognitive phenomenon detailed
in my video can learning make you dumb
they had tunnel vision based on their
experience they also had a lot of
possible evidence to choose from so they
only saw what they wanted to see and
they wanted to see it in a certain way
it's the same mistake we saw with
Brandon Mayfield's fingerprint case and
just like Sally Clark's trial the
prosecution and jury refused to admit
that long odds and crazy coincidences
really do happen they just do or maybe
they just didn't understand that they do
one way to combat the Einstein effect is
to bring in people to look at the
problem who aren't used to operating in
familiar patterns Dallas Morning News
journalist Steve McGonagall and Steve
blow started questioning the District
Attorney's narrative Jim McCloskey of
centurion Ministries in Princeton New
Jersey and his own investigator started
putting the evidence together to get
Joyce exonerated and in 1989 just weeks
after morally safer of 60 Minutes aired
a 14-minute piece detailing the doubt
surrounding Joyce's conviction she was
finally granted a re-trial for the first
time in nine years five months and 24
days Joyce was free and months later the
D.A dropped the case against her Joyce
Ann Brown spent the years following her
release working as an assistant to a
county official before founding an
organization to assist the incarcerated
and their families
she died of a heart attack in 2015.
Joyce's strength and character allowed
her to turn her Injustice into a
springboard to help other people but she
never should have had to do that in the
first place Joyce wrote in her book
Justice denied that she had faith in the
system if you did a crime you did the
time if you were innocent you went free
the thing is lives like Joyce Ann
Brown's have been and will continue to
be destroyed because we keep getting the
same things wrong we fall prey to the
same cognitive biases analytical
fallacies and just plain thinking errors
that I've been exploring on this channel
for years one day it's the Einstein
effect the next day it's confirmation
bias or any of dozens of misintered
rotations in math I know all of these
things you know all of these things but
not everyone else does and their
compounding errors can determine the
freedom of people named well whatever
your first middle and last name is and
as always thanks for watching well the
first thing I'm going to do is spend
some time with my daughter
and that very night I'm gonna sleep in
the bed with my mom
I've been waiting on that day a long
time
Vsauce Kevin here with a math crime so
Sinister that the Michigan Supreme Court
stated no other game operated more
extensively or demoralized so many
people City police forces repeatedly
shut it down and the FBI waged all-out
war against it and it made criminals out
of people like a Detroit mom named Miss
Fanny what they didn't know is that they
were fighting against a nearly perfect
game that was about way more than just
beating the odds
[Music]
in Atlanta it was called playing the bug
in Harlem and elsewhere it's still
called policy after the original game
that Drew numbers from 1 to 78 but the
real name is just numbers and although
it was associated with black communities
everyone played the numbers when Fannie
Davis set up her Detroit neighborhood
numbers game in 1958 there just wasn't
much Economic Opportunity for the black
community so she started her own
business and she funded it after winning
big on numbers herself it worked like
this you'd place a bet on a three-digit
number from zero zero zero to 999 and
that could hit one of two ways you could
play it straight where you hope to hit
the exact number like 607 and you'd be
paid 500 or 600 times your bet or you
could bet a number boxed meaning you'd
win if any combination of your numbers
hit that's three factorial so three
times times 2 times 1 equals 6 possible
combinations and it would pay about
eighty to one okay so how did they
choose the winning number
I've got a cage full of balls numbered
one through one hundred
I'll give this a crank and then I'll
draw three I'm gonna play three nine
four that's my lucky number because 394
was Tony Gwynn's batting average in 1994
when he was on Pace to hit over 400 for
the first time since Ted Williams at 406
in 1941 but a labor strike shortened to
baseball season and ruined everything
okay here we go
[Music]
32 I already lost oh let's keep going
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh balls bro oh man
oh I am a fool oh there's so many on the
floor all right let's finish this off
stay closed
ah 86.
[Music]
last number
91 the winning number was 261. my number
is 394.
sorry Tony but this method is silly no
one would trust a guy pulling balls out
of a cage in his house to get the
winning number in a more fair manner I
could do something like take three
YouTube videos reload them each day on a
live stream and use the ones digit from
The View counts to pick the winning
number and Fanny's game worked kind of
similar to that she used a mutual from a
local race track the betting totals for
win place and show on a series of horse
races she take the ones digit from the
fourth fifth and sixth race totals and
there's your three numbers it was
technically possible to influence those
digits but incredibly difficult and
expensive other games used independent
numbers like digits from the published
daily balance of the US Treasury things
you could open up a newspaper and see
look here's the real beauty of numbers
and why it worked so well for Fannie and
her community you win just often enough
to enjoy playing and to validate every
possible betting system if you play six
days a week you'll probably win boxed
two or three times a year and you'll hit
straight for 500 times your bet every
few years did a number come to you in a
dream do you think you have a scientific
Lottery beating system they all end up
winning and yeah the house Edge was
steep getting paid 500 to 1 on something
you know has a 1 in 1 000 chance of
happening means someone's making money
somewhere they're also taking bets
keeping meticulous records collecting
money from losses and distributing money
from wins all as they're calculating
their own mathematical risk of Ruin in
real time to make sure they can survive
financially if someone hits big but for
Fannie's neighbors they could see one
dollar become 500 overnight the FBI yeah
I saw an opportunity to rip it away from
them and give it to someone else law
enforcement called the numbers game
racketeering and in 1970 the FBI LED
what J Edgar Hoover called the largest
gambling raid in history shutting down
58 numbers operators then governments
realized that if the house always wins
they could just become the house States
made numbers illegal did their best to
wipe it out and then gave themselves a
legal numbers Monopoly
wow what a neat trick lotteries actually
have a really complex history in the
United States from the colonial period
to early statehood hundreds of lotteries
helped raise money for schools and
public works by the 1830s lotteries were
denounced by social reformers as morally
bankrupt predatory games that generated
tainted revenue and in 1895 lottery
games were banned Nationwide from legal
lotteries to policy houses there was
enough corruption and game fixing to
consider what was best for the public
interest Now 44 states have legalized
lotteries and the Powerball is played in
all of them to help raise money for
schools and public works and we've come
full circle
but the reality is to run a game like
numbers what you really need is the
trust of your community Danny Davis and
other Boutique numbers operators engaged
in a sort of prescient Scholarship
Decades before neuroscience and
psychology research confirmed what they
harnessed intuitively the community
element of numbers was everything They
seized the power of dunbar's number
building on the social cohesion in
well-connected neighborhoods so everyone
could play a game together and that's
completely lost when one hundred
thousand strangers play a lottery
anonymously at a gas station they knew
that throwing in just one additional
number meant only hitting straight once
every 30 years that's probably once in a
lifetime and that's just not often
enough for most people to want to keep
playing even if it increases the prizes
dramatically they Intuit did the
communal strength of Renee Gerard's
memetic desire and how much people love
playing games together and need to and
they also knew how to make a small
economy work numbers created tens of
thousands of jobs within communities
trying to survive in the face of
discrimination segregation and rampant
racism a 1903 Detroit Free Press article
said numbers was largely the gambling
field of the ignorant superstitious and
poor the main thing is to have the evil
eternally wiped out Lottery ban
legislation was a patronizing attempt to
protect communities from themselves now
we've got Japan's takarakuji South
Korea's Lotto 645 the U.S Mega Millions
and Russia's goslotto in addition to U.S
state games that operate exactly like
numbers did did decades ago Pennsylvania
even named their three-digit lottery the
daily number but those games can't
possibly do what people like Fannie
Davis did in Detroit there's no talk at
the diner about who won that week or who
hasn't hit in ages there's no knock on
the door to deliver your lucky payout
the day after your numbers match there's
no playing 357 because you live at 357
Park Drive and everyone knowing that
when that number hit you were the winner
that's all gone there's enough Intrigue
about Fannie Davis's life and her
numbers game to fill a great docu-series
and there were thousands like her read
Brigette Davis's book about her mom
that's her story to tell not mine check
out Felicia George's dissertation about
numbers in Detroit or Louise
Meriwether's novel daddy was a number
Runner you've heard a million stories
about the good guys and the bad guys
during prohibition but numbers stories
like Miss fannies have been almost
entirely ignored but they shouldn't be
because alongside the rackets were
people who understood the social fabric
of their communities making your own way
in the world and making everyone else a
little bit happier that's not the
American dream that's everyone's dream
but the highly regulated mass production
of fun strips the complex social
function from a game that's the perfect
blend of math and people it's reduced to
lonely Anonymous gambling
and when that happens the only thing
left is just numbers
and as always thanks for watching
Vsauce Kevin here and I'm about to bust
the greatest female Tycoon of the 19th
century using forensic math I just need
skim milk and amputated leg and a family
of nerds to do it
mid dollars were at stake and it all
came down to handwriting
foreign
[Music]
I've told some stories about how math
has perverted the pursuit of justice and
destroyed lives but when one of
America's richest women tried to steal
even more money math detected her fraud
Petty green was bred to make money and
she was the best at it at six years old
Hedy was reading Financial newspapers to
her father who owned a whaling firm in
Massachusetts she tracked stock prices
with her grandfather and by age 13 was
the family bookkeeper in the 1850s the
family had Millions which in today's
money is tens of millions but had he
needed more and when her aunt died she
saw dollar signs first you need to
understand heady her life was all about
money and she racked up a fortune that
would be valued well into the billions
today
she was known as The Witch of Wall
Street but she was famously miserly she
was just as obsessed with making money
as she was with never spending any of it
here are some examples she spent so long
trying to find a free clinic to treat
her son's leg injury that she waited too
long and it had to be amputated she
refused to use hot water because fuel to
heat it felt like a waste of money she
wore one black dress and a single set of
underwear that she only changed when
they wore out when she bailed out the
New York City government by writing a
check to cover its budgetary shortfalls
she was living in boarding houses
because she wanted to she said just
because I dress plainly and do not spend
a fortune on my gowns they say I am
cranky or insane Hedy green wasn't
insane but she was a criminal and that's
where the math comes in when her aunt
Sylvia died in 1865 her will stipulated
that about 1 million dollars would go to
Charities that's about 15 million today
the other 1 million would be put in a
trust for Hetty so half for charity half
for heady here's what happened next
heady remarkably produced an earlier
copy of the will stating that 100
percent of her aunt's Fortune would go
directly to her which seemed pretty
convenient it also had a page attached
that invalidated any future Wills which
seemed really convenient the Estates
executor Thomas Mandel saw it and was
like I don't think so so what did Hedy
do she sued the estate and that's when
Nerds came to the rescue Charles Sanders
Pierce was a literal genius by age 23 he
had three degrees from Harvard he
eventually became one of America's
greatest logicians including realizing
in 1886 that electrical circuits could
carry out logical operations that
resulted in the digital computer decades
later but in 1865 he entered a courtroom
in Boston to analyze Aunt Sylvia's
handwriting Charles compared 42 samples
of Sylvia's signature and concluded that
it had 30 downstrokes in graphonomics a
ballistic stroke that conveys a distinct
change in the absolute velocity of the
pen my signature has 18. eight in Kevin
10 in Lieber here's a question how
consistent is a signature how much did
Sylvia's vary from sample to sample how
much does mine vary I signed my name and
then I made 42 more signatures and tried
to make them match then I'd judged each
sample against the original signature to
find out how many of the 18 downstrokes
in my name were the same I looked at the
size length and angle to determine
whether each stroke was substantially
similar they followed a normal
distribution and the result was an
average of
7.405 matches out of a possible 18. so
only 41 percent the same and I was
really trying to make them the same
Sylvia's 42 signatures were probably
done over a period of years but the
interesting thing is the variance my
signatures have a standard deviation of
1.326 which means that
99.73 percent of my signatures should
fall between
3.427 and
11.383 that's a range of plus and minus
3 Sigma the z-score of each sample
indicates how many standard deviations
that sample is from the mean basic how
much of an outlier it is my most deviant
sample was 10 matches for a z-score of
1.957 I actually did one more set of
comparisons just to make sure I compared
signature 21 to all the others the mean
was 6.810 matches and the standard
deviation was
1.418 the highest z-score was still only
2.249 based on my 42 samples how deviant
would a perfect 18 for 18 match actually
be it would have a z-score of
7.989 nearly eight standard deviations
from the mean the odds of a signature
being seven standard deviations from the
mean are about 1 in 390 billion the odds
of 7.989 uh figure it out and tell me in
the comments back to heady Charles
Pierce found that Sylvia's 42 sample had
an average of six downward Strokes
matching the Will's signature so about
twenty percent and conformed to a
binomial distribution just like mine and
probably yours when Charles compared the
signature on the first page of the will
to the signature on the attached second
page he found that all 30 downstrokes
were a perfect match a 100 percent
perfect match his father Benjamin Pierce
was a Harvard mathematician he testified
that the probability of Sylvia's second
signature being a perfect 30 for 30
match was
2.666 times 10 raised to the power of 21
or 1 in two sextillion 666 quintillion
so yeah Benjamin Pierce said such
evanescent Shadows of probability cannot
belong long to actual life which is an
amazing quote uh yeah heady traced and
Sylvia's signature she lost the case and
fled with her husband to London when the
family threatened to have her indicted
for fraud but she didn't really lose
after five years in court she was
awarded six hundred thousand dollars
from the estate less than the original
legitimate will gave her but still 12
million dollars in today's money and the
state never brought criminal charges
against the wealthiest woman living in
it the following year Hedy had a
daughter who she named Sylvia Teddy
green died during a heated argument with
her maid about the benefits of skim milk
today her estate would be valued at 5
billion dollars she really was America's
first female business tycoon and she
wasn't all bad she became an anonymous
philanthropist and served as a nurse to
care for friends and family in 1951
Sylvia green died leaving over 99 of the
family fortune to charity I've made
videos about the crazy odds of two
people having the same name and having
weirdly similar fingerprints and having
rare tragedies strike twice in the same
family I've shown that math alone is a
terrible basis for convicting someone of
a crime and insane odds can still mean
innocence with Sylvia Anne howland's
will we have to consider the totality of
the circumstances hedy's motive her
obsessive greed her miraculous
production of a will that just happened
to be entirely in her favor all combined
with truly astronomy chemical signature
odds knowing when not to believe in
coincidences is just as crucial as
accepting them one in a billion okay if
one in a billion people won a lottery
that means about eight people alive
right now would hit the jackpot it's not
impossible a mountain of evidence plus
one in 2.6 sextillion yeah I don't think
so Eddie Hedy greens spent a lifetime
accumulating money power and influence
and she could never get enough of any of
it but in the end all of hedy's precious
Millions couldn't compete with the
Pierce family's sextillions and as
always thanks for watching
so there's an important point about why
I chose these stories their statistical
outliers they're the extremes most cases
don't need multi-year analysis of
expected Health outcomes or pouring over
30 downstrokes of 42 different
signatures these stories are interesting
because they're unusual but anomalies
and aberrations often lay bare the
problems we have with the mundane
Brandon Mayfield's case happened after
100 Years of forensic fingerprint
analysis that's a full Century of
misunderstandings
highlighting the extremes is often the
most compelling and Illuminating way to
understand how generally fragile our
grip is on Concepts like basic
probability or identifying your attacker
we've spent thousands of years trying to
understand and refine Justice
and we're just getting started
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you
[Music]